è molto bello essere qui anche se per
grande parte della società
non avremo
in effetti durante
ho dovuto trovare la vostra estensione
invece mi pare a giudicare dal numero
delle persone che vedo che non è andata
così
sono venuto a raccontarvi quella che io
ritengo essere una bella storia una
storia di una specie magnifica è una
specie che ha avuto tanta paura
quindi vi parlerò della loro paura che
poi in effetti anche la nostra paura e
poi vi parlerò della mente la mente che
in questo incessante tentativo di farci
sopravvivere non esita ad imbrogliare c
infine vi parlo del coraggio il coraggio
e una cosa che abbiamo inventato per
difenderci da noi stessi io ho paura
come homo sapiens 80 paura qualcuno mi
ha chiesto ma cos'è questa fissazione
per la paura perché ti interessi così
tanta la paura io sono formatore un
educatore ho lavorato per tanti anni con
i gruppi e con le persone singole e ho
scoperto quanto la paura possa essere
capace di bloccare tutte le nostre
aspirazioni
la paura ha il sapore del metallo sulla
lingua ricorda un po quello del sangue
non so se avete presente è qualcosa che
veramente può disturbarci la peggiore di
tutte è la paura della paura
funziona con i pregiudizi preconcetti le
preoccupazioni pre appunto prima che
succedano e fa venir fuori quelle voci
ne che sentiamo e che io in questo
momento sento lascia perdere vai via
non è il caso ma sei sicuro che poi hai
abbastanza informazioni ma dai che non
ti piace non è per te dai ti guardano
tutti
ecco questo è un meccanismo complesso è
anche molto semplice il meccanismo
funziona più o meno così la nostra mente
recepisce dei dati degli stimoli
dall'esterno
immediatamente scatta un allarme e in
onda il sangue con sostanze che ci fanno
reagire le reazioni sono di tre tipi
la prima è scappare la seconda è
combattere è la terza è bloccarsi ecco
devo dire che questa nostra mente lo fa
per proteggerci a un grosso interesse a
farci arrivare a fine della corsa ma è
anche un po egoista perché pensa a se
stessa pensa a proteggere se stessa a
consumare poche energie a questo istinto
di autoconservazione
e per fare questo non esita a mentirci
ci manda delle immagini che non sono la
realtà non sono la verità
per esempio io cammino in un bosco vedo
un ramo dalla forma sinusoidale a terra
e immediatamente ecco l'immagine di un
serpente mi proteggo ma non è la verità
è una bugia
in questo modo la nostra mente può
trasformarsi in un'entità bloccante in
qualche modo diventa un pessimo padrone
mi chiedo e vi chiedo se non vi è mai
capitato di cercare di fare la scelta
giusta
la cosa giusta faccio la cosa giusta ci
penso
pensaci più volte pensaci 10 secondi
prima di agire
ma cos'è la cosa giusta in assoluto
ogni volta che scegliamo lasciamo da
parte altre cose quanti di noi a causa
della paura non portano sulle spalle
qualche rimorso o qualche rimpianto bene
per capire come funziona tutto questo mi
sono permesso di tornare indietro nel
tempo e vedere come l'evoluzione in
qualche modo ha condizionato questa
storia ricordate che il coraggio lo
abbiamo inventato e lo abbiamo inventato
proprio per difenderci dalla nostra
paura
parliamo del nostro antenato l'homo
sapiens 100 mila anni fa
vivevamo in un ambiente naturale
abbastanza confortevole un bel po di
risorse a disposizione qualche predatore
di troppo ma comunque si viveva una vita
decente
poi improvvisamente dei cambiamenti
climatici repentini repentine si fa per
dire perché si parla di ere hanno
trasformato il nostro ambiente naturale
da così a così la savana e nella savana
non ci sentivamo più tanto a nostro agio
c'erano molti predatori e homo sapiens
non voleva fare da pasto al leone aliene
così per qualche motivo inspiegabile 70
mila anni fa ha deciso di puntare verso
nord ed è partito un viaggio incredibile
un viaggio verso l'ignoto verso
l'incertezza un viaggio di 70 mila anni
pensate diretto verso nord alla scoperta
affrontando l'ignoto l'ignoto diventa
un'opportunità
con loro avevano tanta paura e qualche
attrezzo utensile di selce
niente più il 70 mila anni si imparano
però tante cose e lomo sapienza ha
voluto sempre esplorare ed innovare
esplorare ed innovare
finchè alla fine non ha trovato il
continente europeo e lì ha trovato una
culla dove in qualche modo a fermarsi ma
sempre continuando ad esplorare e
innovare poi 40.000 anni fa
probabilmente durante una battuta di
caccia si imbatte nel suo cugino più
sofisticato e anche più affascinante
l'uomo di neanderthal l'uomo di
neanderthal
è forte e veloce è perfettamente
adattata ai climi freddi è un predatore
incredibilmente efficace e i due per un
po di tempo con dividono tante
esperienze e probabilmente anche un po
di dna e cosa succede che adottano
comportamenti completamente diversi i
tempi sono duri per tutti ma l'uomo
sapiens decide di praticare il nomadismo
non si ferma mai
non si accontenta di quello che sa vuole
vedere dietro le montagne circa la
grande acqua esplora il neanderthal vive
in una piccola zona la sfrutta al
massimo e quando le risorse vengono a
mancare l'abbandona sapiens osa unirsi
ad altri individui esterni al gruppo
familiare e quindi rischia anche un po
questo per scambiare conoscenze e crea
le prime proto tribù neanderthal invece
gruppo familiare poche persone pochi
individui e ovviamente soffre
dell'impoverimento del codice genetico e
della mortalità femminile sapiens innova
sempre sembra incessantemente
interessata a migliorare i suoi utensili
cambiano e diventano sempre più
sofisticati anche le tecniche di caccia
neanderthal invece per migliaia di anni
fa sempre le stesse cose
infine sapiens inventa il linguaggio un
codice sofisticato che serve a
scambiarsi la conoscenza e saperi
neanderthal non ha molto da condividere
e quindi sapiens sopravvive neanderthal
si estingue darwin il nostro amato
darwin aveva ragione è la specie più
capace di adattarsi al cambiamento a
sopravvivere e sicuramente lo fa a spese
di quella più forte e così è stato dal
punto di vista biologico ma non solo
anche dal punto di vista dei
comportamenti i nostri progenitori hanno
avuto il coraggio
di adottare comportamenti sociali nuovi
ed efficace in un contesto di continuo
cambiamento come quello dell'era
glaciale in ogni homo sapiens proprio in
tutti esiste un innata spinta ad osare
per affrontare la paura
noi siamo una specie che ha
un'incredibile capacità di desiderare e
questo ci espone all'incertezza dopo di
me su questo palco sentirete storia
incredibile persone che si sono persi in
oceano in tempesta altri che stanno
immaginando addirittura un viaggio su
marte persone che hanno sfidato malattie
molto serie e inabilitanti e lo hanno
fatto sempre senza cercare l'assoluta
sicurezza perché l'assoluta sicurezza
impedisce il soddisfacimento delle
nostre aspirazioni e allora sono venuto
qui a dirvi che nella mia esperienza
professionale ho scoperto che la paura
ha un origine biologica e sarà sempre
con noi non si può eliminare non
possiamo non avere paura
il coraggio invece il coraggio un'altra
cosa
il coraggio è una competenza il coraggio
si impara il coraggio si allena il
coraggio e la quantità di incertezza con
la quale siamo disposti a convivere se
noi coglieremo questa opportunità
riusciremo a crescere e fare del
cambiamento
una vera nuova chance
in questo modo mi potrò permettere di
dire che la mia mente da pessimo padrone
diventerà ottimo servitore e allora in
questi tempi di incertezza dove in
questo mondo sembra andare talmente
veloce da non potergli star dietro tutto
cambia
e siamo un po sopraffatti dagli eventi
in questi tempi credo che sia utile
avere una donna e un uomo nuovo neo
sapiens appunto neo sapiens non più homo
sapiens non abbiamo più bisogno
gli altri muri di filo spinato di leggi
che regolano tutto quello che ci
circonda
non abbiamo bisogno di unirci in altre
tribù che combattono nuove tribù sotto
simboli antichi sapiens sopravvive ad
ogni simbolo e ad ogni ideologia non
abbiamo bisogno di tante abilità e nuove
tecnologie quanto di avere empatia ed
esercitare comprensione
ci serve umanità e tanta roba ma
tranquilli
queste cose non dobbiamo farle da soli
guardatevi intorno chi sono queste
persone seduta vicino a voi chi c'è
questo teatro girate la testa guardateli
chi sono tutti questi perché sono venuti
qui oggi perché avete scelto di dedicare
questa giornata alti al ted con chi
avete scelto di venire al ted
questa è la nostra tribù questa è la
tribù con cui dobbiamo imparare a
riunirci di nuovo ma veramente come
hanno fatto i nostri progenitori è
importantissimo imparare ri imparare a
comunicare con profondità ea condividere
i nostri bisogni
e importante essere generosi e
condividere i nostri saperi mettere le
competenze al servizio di una grande
tribù ma soprattutto è importante avere
il coraggio di cambiare tutto
se riusciremo a cogliere questo
insegnamento
se ci riusciremo avremo un opportunità e
per questo motivo io vi dico che la
grande opportunità di crescere di
progredire per la razza umana passa
attraverso la necessità di accertare
l'incertezza in questo modo
ci riusciremo come 70 mila anni fa come
sempre
e allora vi chiedo qual è la quantità di
incertezza che siete disposti ad
accettare oggi qual è la sfida che
volete raccogliere oggi in questo teatro
darwin aveva ragione se non cambia ogni
estingue è questa qui è la chiave della
nostra sopravvivenza
grazie per aver ascoltato